good to go are you all set ken you're
ready
okay well i appreciate the time i think
what i'll do is um
i know it's a little awkward uh doing
things like this you guys are getting a
lot more used to it than probably even i
am um and i don't want to be repetitive
i i hope everyone had at least had a
chance to
look at the initial budget presentation
that we did again
you know one of the hard parts about
doing it virtually is that you know
you're not
there with you know really presenting it
on a one-on-one basis with the house but
what we also try to do is show some
charts and graphs
because it really is uh talking about a
budget without showing any numbers is
always a very challenging
thing so in some ways it created an
opportunity uh to show some of the
things you want to highlight
and give a little historical perspective
on some of these numbers and
and some of the dynamics that we're
talking about so if you'll bear with me
i'm happy to go through a few of these
things and then
there's a few other things that we
didn't quite get to in the initial
budget presentation but are
worthwhile and no and uh worth noting
for a variety of different reasons but
what we really tried to do in the
initial presentation was really hit all
those high points all those things that
uh for the most part i we think can have
the biggest impact positive impact on
people's lives where we are
and the opportunities uh as we move
forward so
um if you'll bear with me um obviously
let's just start with with where we were
and and i don't you don't need the
governor to explain to you the
the really that all the challenges and
the pitfalls of of the last year
um they go well beyond just the economic
impacts they go
to our communities and in society
without a doubt one of the first things
we did you know
knowing how severe this was going to be
back in march and april of last year
we knew that it was going to have a huge
economic impact whether it was just for
a few weeks a few months or even
potentially longer
so when the economic impacts of the
pandem pandemic really undercut what at
the time was
uh one of the strongest economies in the
state's history um
we did take very decisive action uh we
faced a lot of uncertainty and that can
be very scary
but it also means you have to step up
and and make some very tough decisions
the budget shortfall that we looked at
was predicted working with department of
revenue was
predicted anywhere between 350 and 400
million dollars
by taking some the actions of both
managing expenses
uh instilling a hiring freeze um just
being i think tight on a lot of things
we even
pushed out a few of the capital projects
not because even if the ones we didn't
want to push out because there were no
workers people then you know it was hard
to get folks to actually
keep committing to those projects
because it was such an unknown future
but that also created
the opportunity to not have to expend
that cash until we really got a handle
on what was going to happen with our
economy and we were able over time
to really reduce that that hole if you
will to about a 50 million dollar
uh shortfall not a 350 million dollar
shortfall which is obviously a
a lot more manageable in a variety of
different ways um
the end education trust fund which again
no one has was really sure where that
was going to end up
but now it's projected to end the
biennium with a positive balance
the long-standing uh highway fund
deficit
has been substantially reduced and the
fish and game
we saw a lot more people hunting and
fishing and getting their license and
recreating they were
spending their their uh either their
what they were bringing home and pay
they wanted to be outside and be healthy
uh a lot of folks were getting
unemployment checks or whatever it was
the unemployment stipend
and they wanted to spend it in a way
that they could spend time with their
families outdoors and that has
really boosted um the fish and game fund
to really
levels we haven't seen in many many
years and all that
you know created opportunity for us
so putting all that opportunity in terms
of what we were managing through 2020
together
allowed us to create a balanced budget
and that's the most important thing is
truly balanced within itself we don't
use a cent of any sort of speculative
federal money not a penny of money that
hasn't been
voted on or spent or authorized out of
the federal government this budget
relies on not a penny of that i know
there's a lot of talk about that up
there
but it's it's not even an exaggeration
it's 100 percent
untrue so we really have a budget that
lives within its own means
it cuts taxes as a lot of folks have
heard and no it increases
the municipal revenue sharing we always
talk about the fact that the state
cannot control
directly property taxes but what we can
do is send back cash
and send back opportunity that would
help offset otherwise
local costs and so this budget i think
there's a couple very creative things
in terms of allowing us to to do more
municipal revenue sharing
and also help hopefully make and
maintain that obligation of more
municipal revenue sharing
it downshifts nothing it really in terms
of burden
in terms of cost to those municipalities
we also include 30 million dollars in
one-time aid to schools for
capital investments infrastructure
energy efficiency projects whatever
the schools want we're really building
on that school infrastructure fund that
we created
a couple years ago specifically at the
time for safe school infrastructure and
we put a lot of money into that
we're keeping that same fund we're just
broadening the ability of local school
districts to use these
state matching grants for whatever they
they want in terms of capital projects
that one-time spending
which again really takes the burden off
some of the local districts allows
districts
to do projects that they otherwise
weren't able to do in the past
we talk a lot about the tax relief and
and that's a big one for me because
when i've spent a lot of time with
businesses over the past year they all
want the opportunity to bring
workers back in they all want the
opportunity to reinvest in capital
reinvest in equipment whatever it might
be
and really every dollar helps so what we
tried to do is not just create tax
relief for businesses but for everyone
um and and i really wanted to make sure
that we were covering the entire
spectrum there
so it doesn't create any new taxes
that's another one it's not just that
we've cut
taxes sometimes you've seen people cut
taxes over here but they raise taxes
over there
this does none of that no new taxes or
fees no increases
in taxes or fees um and it doesn't play
any sort of political games there's
nothing buried in here there's nothing
hidden in here
what we try to do is write it very
simply very upfront um
and transparent if anything we've we've
tried to be very transparent about
everything we do
over the last year um so first with the
meals and rooms tax a lot of folks have
been talking about this
uh my budget reduces the meals and rooms
tax from nine percent down to eight and
a half percent
um and that just helps folks either take
a
people want to go out to get a meal it
takes a little bit off that bill it
takes a little bit of the burden off the
business
um it allows everybody to to benefit in
that and hopefully
we can you know continue some of those
reductions in in future budgets and
future years
it obviously helps small businesses by
reducing the business enterprise tax
from 0.6
down to 0.55 percent and then the big
one that on the business enterprise tax
is really increasing that filing
threshold
moving the filing threshold up to 250
will effectively take tens of thousands
of businesses maybe even up to 30
35 000 businesses won't even have to
file that tax anymore
that's a that's a savings for the state
that's a savings for that business
uh the net of the net impact of that is
a as a few million dollars so we can
manage around that
but just the ability to take so many of
those small businesses entrepreneur
businesses
that are already laced with too much
regulate regulation and paperwork
getting them off of that and and really
allowing them to do what they should be
doing is focusing on their business
instead of worrying about paying
the state taxes um i think that that's a
huge opportunity for small businesses in
the state
and then i think the big one is is a tax
that has been
talked about we've been talking about
getting rid of it for literally 50 years
in this state
and that's the interest and dividends
tax um it we we take it in i think in
2023 we go from five down to four
percent
and then the idea is that we can
gradually reduce that phase that to zero
and really give seniors retirees they're
the ones that just benefit that is just
cash in their pockets to reinvest
whether it's in their families or their
communities
or give them a little more flexibility
to stay in this state
you know we don't want people to be
running down to florida we don't want
people to be
running down and retiring in other
states we want them retiring and
creating opportunity here people are
living longer they're retiring for a
longer amount of time
and so the more opportunity we create
for those seniors and retirees to keep
that money in their pockets
we become a magnet not just for small
businesses and young families
which we're already doing a phenomenal
job with but we're also providing that
opportunity on the other end of the
spectrum
that again those are dollars that are
going to be reinvested right back into
our economy
education funding always a hot topic you
know we're projected to end this
biennium with a positive balance
of more than 50 million dollars in the
education trust fund
and the strength of that really means
that you know if more students were
to return back to public schools we know
that a lot of students left public
schools
they took other options as schools were
closing or finding their own models
we're assuming a good amount of those
students come back but even if more come
back into the model
we have a cushion there we have
flexibility
to make sure that the state can meet its
financial obligation
for students coming back in
it spends more money for students in the
biennium than ever
before it's a very important one if you
look at the dollars we're spending per
student
uh we broke the record in the last
budget uh that i proposed and we're
breaking the record yet again in this
budget so more dollars per student
than ever before and then for those i
know there's a lot of municipalities and
i know a lot of representatives have
probably heard from their their
superintendents about this free and
reduced lunch
issue and and basically we clean that up
is what we do
you know because folks didn't have to go
through the traditional paperwork and
and regulatory barriers to get their
free and reduced lunch we really made it
through the federal government we made
it very available to everyone that was
great
um but because of that there's less
people actually technically applying for
free
free and reduced lunch so we know the
need is there but it's hard to figure
out who's applying and what that does is
that really messes with
really the the formula that we use to
grant adequacy back to cities and towns
this budget cleans all that up really we
move on to kind of a better system
so that um if that issue were to persist
we we don't have
a short change we're not shortchanging
cities and towns in terms of what we'd
be giving them and that's
i know that's been a very big issue for
manchester and especially a lot of the
larger cities that have a lot of
students on free and reduced lunch
and the whole point of this budget is we
clean that up we fix our formula and we
make sure
again we're meeting that obligation for
our students we're meeting that adequacy
as it comes to education funding um
so when you add that up or i should say
even over and above that we're also
allowing for up to 15 million in
additional revenue sharing now
so we have um through municipalities
over the biennium so when you add all
the revenue sharing opportunities up
uh it totals as much as 78 million
dollars
by fiscal year 2023 and revenue sharing
so it's 78 million
back to cities and towns uh over and
above the operations of the state which
again is is all just about
uh allowing them to uh kind of off
off shift a little bit
what the locally local property
taxpayers would have would have
traditionally been paying
we can pick up some of that cost um for
them
you know another thing i didn't get a
chance that we didn't we didn't talk
about in the presentation that we did
but
an important thing that my budget is
also looking to do is create some
changes with the unemployment trust fund
um you know when when we hit 17
unemployment very very quickly uh the
federal government stepped up and they
helped us with a lot of the unemployment
opportunity but
our own fund took its own hit i think
most states in the country
uh have are actually in the process of
borrowing money from the federal
government
just to keep their unemployment trust
fund solvent we never had to do that we
managed
very very well and commissioner cabadis
and
deputy commissioner laborers deserve a
lot of the credit for that they did a
phenomenal job
with our unemployment trust fund the
level of abuse and waste and fraud was
really really minimal here it might be
even one of the lowest in the country
we're not sure but we think we're the
best in the country
where other states were literally
wasting hundreds of millions of dollars
we became very efficient with it now
that created
the opportunity of us not having to
borrow from the federal government
we invested cares act money one of the
few states that invested
a substantial amount of care zach money
about 50 million i put in
to the unemployment trust fund as well
and so what my budget is really
proposing to do the changes to the trust
fund
is to strategically build the trust
during strong economic times
to reduce that financial burden on
businesses during the downturns
so what it what it really does is as our
trust fund drops
we typically hit businesses with
addition an additional tax and
and an additional surcharge and what we
do is we move those threshold levels and
we get rid of the surcharge
think about it as the trust fund drops
that's happening in tough economic times
and we're actually increasing taxes on
businesses while they're struggling the
most
so it doesn't really make much sense so
we're trying to really
change that model and just by moving
some of the thresholds and being able
that allows us to remove those
surcharges and still maintain
a very healthy trust fund and i know uh
both matt
melo and um and deputy commissioner
lavers will talk a lot more about that
in detail but it's a real opportunity to
kind of modernize
you know this crisis allowed us to
really look at our system in depth
see how it works in in levels of very
high stress
and i think come back with some very
proactive ideas uh about just how to
make it more viable for the future
um strengthening the rainy day fund i i
just i'm a huge believer in saving
i really am and and you know i don't
want to say that we just got lucky we
really managed very very well
but there's a lot of states who just had
to drain every bit of their rainy day
fund down
during this economic crisis luckily we
didn't have to do that but we
effectively have a cap
on our rainy day fund i just
fundamentally disagree with
putting a cap on any sort of savings
account so this budget also proposes
moving that threshold
to to hit a 10 percent of the revenue
raised over the biennium it effectively
doubles the amount we could put in the
rainy day fund
to ballpark 300 million dollars um when
it rains it pours and and again we hope
we never have to have another pandemic
like this
but without a doubt um you know capping
the rainy day fund
is from a long-term strategy strategic
point of view
can be a very risky thing and
potentially risk higher taxes and
increase fees and surcharges and all of
this in the future
um if we're having to create new taxes
just to fill in budgetary holes
that could have been done by just uh you
know saving a little better
uh in the short term i talk a lot about
student debt assistance
um you know when we talk about re you
know rebuilding our economy we know
businesses they're already coming here
which is great
they want to expand here but the
limitation that businesses have is is
twofold number one
workforce number two housing and those
are very directly connected now i have a
a housing bill that i've we put a
bipartisan housing bill
uh forward a lot of folks and
republicans and democrats in the house
and the senate
are charging forward with that i think
it's a great bill and it really creates
incentives not penalties
but incentives for local communities to
make those investments
uh in in housing uh if you don't have
the housing you can't
you if the people if the workers that
you need for a business to go from a
thousand employees to 1300 employees
if they literally have no place to live
the workers can't come
and so if you want to be pro-business if
you want to support local businesses
big and small you have to find a way to
create
housing in new hampshire and we're not
coming in with a a hammer
saying you know we're going to take over
the housing programming process and all
the localities absolutely not local
control
must be respected it really what
separates us but at the same time
that does come with the responsibility
of moving forward on a local level
with a lot of the housing opportunities
the other piece there is student debt
assistance we know we're one of the
highest
when it comes to states in the country
with students with some of the highest
debt load
it's right here in new hampshire now we
create a lot of economic opportunity
we're one of the wealthiest states in
the country we have some of the highest
wages
but our students still have a lot of
debt load so i'm reproposing what i
proposed in the last budget which is
using the fees that are collected off
our 529 plan not taxes but the fees
as folks all across the country buy our
529 plan
um and we have one of the best 529 plans
uh programs in the country which is why
why we really collect
more fees than we've ever imagined
instead of just dumping that into these
college endowments that just sit there
we're going to take those dollars and
reinvest them into
student debt assistance and if you stay
and work
here in new hampshire we'll help pay
down your student debt it helps retain
workforce it helps lower the student
debt
it's not just this free college nonsense
that's being discussed down in
washington
um where again it absolves people of the
responsibility
where essentially if you think of it
buying those workers we're incentivizing
those workers
to stay and work and hopefully raise
their families right here in new
hampshire and that encourages more
businesses to come
they can take advantage of that
opportunity and help set us apart from
everyone else in the northeast so it's
those types of things
that can set us apart and set us on a
very very positive economic path
in terms of economic growth encouraging
businesses to come in and most
importantly encouraging that next
generation of workforce
to live work and play right here in new
hampshire we talk a lot about paid leave
voluntary paid leave it has to happen
there's no reason why paid leave should
not be happening here in new hampshire
and the voluntary plan we put forward is
very simple
it's been backed by literally a dozen
different businesses uh have looked at
this model across the country
said they want to be part of it and make
sure that the state doesn't become the
insurance company
as the old plan does it allows real
insurance companies to
take on the financial risk to be the
actuarials and simply by
providing paid leave for all of the
state employees
10 000 of them the premiums drop to rock
bottom levels
and you allow all the other businesses
across the state to participate in that
program
with very low premiums if they choose
and employees
if they choose it's just up to them by
it really is founded in this idea that
we're going to create
very low premiums at the state level by
employ by providing the program for all
of our state employees
and then everybody gets to benefit from
that everyone gets to enjoy those low
premium benefits
on a voluntary basis you don't have to
mandate it you don't have to force
anybody in
it stays economically viable that's been
proven and tried and true through all
the actuarials
and that's the real opportunity that i
think a lot of us have in when we talk
about
the gold standard doing paid leave the
right way
of law enforcement accountability this
is another issue that i know a lot of
you
will be taking up um the the leak
commission came out with
uh i think 48 different recommendations
many of which were able to do through
executive order some are
passing through and being discussed in
in the legislative bodies now
um and they all pass unanimously which
is tremendous but there are some
programs there that also need a little
bit of funding whether it's
you know making sure the police
standards and training have what they
have and i got to tell you i
if you have the chance to spend some
time with john skipper who is now the
new director at police standards and
training he's phenomenal
uh he's he's the right thinker the right
way the right approach
great customer mentality great
connection with all local law
enforcement
and you know he's really driving the
boat on a lot of this and he's just done
a phenomenal job
so we make sure that we're funding those
programs and those opportunities it
could be
cameras for our state police it could be
the million dollar matching dollars that
we've put in
for your local governments if your local
police want to do cameras or dashboard
cams
we'll help provide matching grants for
that which i think is a tremendous
opportunity to making sure
we're not just saying we're going to be
accountable in concord but really making
sure this is a community effort
up and down new hampshire from from
canada to massachusetts from maine to
vermont
here in the 603 every community needs to
be part of that solution
doesn't mean we're going to agree on
every last detail of course there's a
lot of hashing out the legislature is
going to have to work on
but the i think the vast majority of
where we know this needs to go we're all
on the same boat on this
and providing some of the funds to make
that a reality not just talk about it
but really make it a reality
uh is really a priority of the
administration and is is built into the
budget
in a balanced way um a few more things i
know i'm going kind of fast i want to
get to questions so
just bear with me um the community
college and the university system merger
everyone's been talking about that a bit
um it's i don't want to say it's very
simple it's actually very very complex
but the process we're going to start is
very simple and that's bringing the
boards together so bringing a few
members of the university board a few
members of the community college board
and simply saying that if we're going to
have everyone just live in their same
old silos going about at the same old
way
we're going to get left behind there's
that's not a debate that is an absolute
fact
and it's not being left behind ten years
from now it's being left behind like two
and three years from now
this is a non-partisan bipartisan effort
there's absolutely no politics involved
here which is
very good that kind of removes that bad
variable from the equation if you will
and simply says how do we make it a
streamlined process for our students
for our faculty how do we challenge
ourselves to
uh look at how how do we challenge
ourselves to look at how
we ask students to pay right maybe the
different payment plans that we can
we can create this different
opportunities different opportunities
for research and development
projects for students that otherwise
would have never been able to to be
exposed to that
different opportunities for the
four-year college student to actually
have more hands-on learning
that is provided in the community
college which is more necessary than
ever now for a viable workforce so
and and really raising up i mean let's
face it the community college
system is phenomenal in new hampshire it
is phenomenal
but it's it sometimes is treated as a
second tier system
it's not it's not those students those
faculty
they are just as viable if not more so
with some of their skills
than a lot of the opportunities we're
creating just in the university system
and so now bringing everyone together
on an even par not one over-the-air
other but a true partnership
and allowing them to help figure out
some of these details i think is the
opportunity
we just i don't think it's a question we
we have to we have to allow that to
happen
and not it'll save us some money it
might cost us a little money in the
short term maybe it saves us some money
in the long term
this isn't just about a budgetary move
by any means this is about a modern 21st
century education system
that is streamlined that's seamless do
you know our system
has hundreds of agreements within it
that says
these credits in this class can transfer
to these credits with this university
and these credits in this university
transfer to these credits over here
there's literally hundreds of agreements
that are floating around there on the
back end it's so convoluted
why not have a single system a single
process make it seamless
on the back end seamless on the front
end raise everybody
to a level where they are picking their
path in higher education
and we're not just you know trying to
cram them into the the old-fashioned
silos
so a lot of a lot of opportunity there i
talked about the department of energy
and i'm going to bring that up because i
know a lot of folks in the house have
been asking about it
right now we have our public utility
commission there are essentially our
judges
that will debate and adjudicate on
rates and things of that nature but at
the same time manage a department
that's also managing policy it's a
massive conflict of interest and again
no politics involved here folks on both
sides of the aisle i think are thrilled
that we're finally separating those two
parts
you know they'll be connected
administratively but let the judges do
the judging
and let the department do the
departmenting if you will and uh and by
separating those two i think you're just
going to create
a lot of opportunity because
the conflict of interest start really
disappearing
and so that's really what that's about
it's just taking a a system that has
grown big and it's very important system
but mixing having judges be managers of
a department
managing policy that they have to then
adjudicate on
just doesn't make any sense and and you
get a lot of recusals and all this sort
of thing so
that's more of a simple simplification
of the process and i think it's been
received very very well so far
um let's talk a little bit about health
and human services so
a couple things we modernize a lot of
the it infrastructure in health and
human services
in this budget which i think is is a
huge opportunity
there's long-term structural investments
there we keep our commitments we
increase funding for the dd community
we keep our commitments to dcyf that has
been doing a phenomenal job i showed on
the chart
uh in my brother budget presentation
that where
the number of cases of cases per worker
when i first became governor was 80 90
close to 90 per worker and we've gotten
that down to about a dozen very
manageable level
and we still have vacancies which is
great so we can still fill those
vacancies
but we create efficiencies within those
those systems and just get
the product out which is better better
services for those kids
better attention one-on-one attention
for those kids and those families
that's what's going to get better
results and whether it's talking about
saving money in the long run or just
getting these kids on a better path it's
all win
and so those investments have already
started paying off huge dividends
um you know we talked about the medicaid
rate increases a very contentious part
of the last budget
we said would raise the rates 3.1
percent and then 3.1 percent
we're not going back on that commitment
a lot of folks said we should i won't do
it
i think we have to maintain that
commitment i'm a big believer in
promises made our promises kept
and so keeping that 3.1 percent increase
for the full biennium
and moving forward is very important
this budget also does things just uh a
couple of last minute things and then
i'll i'll be quiet for questions but
uh we kind of modernized the adult
parole board uh we've had some issues
with the adult parole board in
a variety of fashion and so what we do
is we kind of just rebuild it
re-modernize it
reorganize it if you will we digitize
the board's day-to-day operations we
definitely save a lot of money and
efficiency in doing that
um you know what i'm a big believer also
in unifor unifying are dispatching
functions so
you know fish and game has a dispatching
center over there for a while marine
patrol had a dispatching center over
there safety had a dispatching center
over there
we brought marine patrol in to to safety
a few years ago and it's worked very
very well
one of the outliers right now is fish
and game so we're going to bring them
back in
as well and make sure it's a unified
system because at the end of the day
when it comes to health and safety in
this state at least
it's all hands on deck it's not about
silos local works very
very well with state and federal
partners
they work from town to town and county
to county
we're we're very we do it really really
well
in terms of the seamless communication
of safety but we still have this
this for whatever reason fish and game
was never dispatchers never included i
think we just need to
include it and now something else you'll
see not so much in this budget but we're
already moving forward with
is called mutual link which links up
hospitals to our dispatching centers
schools to our dish dispatching centers
so it really is a seamless communication
protocol up and down
and again we just want to make sure
everybody is part of those opportunities
so again you know i'll i'll kind of back
up and leave it there
you guys know the budget a lot better
i i just want to reiterate this budget
is balanced within itself i've just
heard
some of this talk that we are counting
on additional federal assistance
zero not a penny of additional federal
assistance is needed
to balance this budget uh that would be
a very irresponsible thing to do
right we may get other federal
assistance and that'll be great and
we'll deal with that when it comes it'll
likely be one-time money for one-time
projects
you would never want to use that in
operational costs anyways and we
count on none of that not for our
capital budgets uh none of it now if it
comes
the legislature will have a big hand in
terms of how those dollars are spent and
making sure that we can spend it very
very well
but that has nothing to do with this
budget i just want to be very very clear
on that
um and i think whatever whatever changes
are made and however the legislature
decides to go
i'm a big believer that the opportunity
to spend any of our extra money
any of the savings we're able to achieve
through this process sending it back to
cities and towns off shooting offsetting
some of those costs that they bear
it's such an important part of this um
increasing that room
that you know moving the rooms and meals
threshold not just lowering the tax
but by moving the threshold and getting
closer to the commitment that we made
the cities and towns years ago
putting another 15 million dollars in
that rooms and meals commitment
is an absolute huge step um every year
we pass a budget that suspends that
right we got to move beyond that and so
we kind of move that we don't quite get
there this year
but over time i think we can but we get
closer to that and again it's all just
cash that goes back to those cities and
towns that they've never that they've
never been able to have before while at
the same time having a room in meals tax
cut i mean think about it we're cutting
the room and meals tax
and sending 15 million more back to
cities that's a huge win
a huge win and we still have a balanced
budget so i think there's a lot of
opportunity there and i know you know
you folks have
have dealt with this a lot more than i
have you've looked at these numbers in
many ways a lot more than i have and
because your constituents will be
very active i'm sure in pushing
different different things but
um i just think that there's great
opportunity here we're in great economic
times and and you know as we come out of
this much better than we ever thought i
think
that this summer is going to be
absolutely phenomenal with travel
tourism room and meals all of it is
going to really be booming
and so you know we don't want a budget
process to hold us up there we want the
budget process to create opportunity
there so we can maximize it
for the citizens of the state and with
that i'll uh i'll be quiet and we can
take some questions whether lisa and
matt
and the whole team are here for you
whatever you need and and again please
understand we'll answer everything we
can here
but if there's certain details we can't
answer we'll we'll just
we'll put a package together with all
the questions and be sure to send
something uh over to the committee as
soon as we can with
any of the details that you're looking
for
thank you very much governor so you want
us to hold the
questions for matt no
all right no i mean that's here i'm matt
are you on
i am on i'm not on video so like they
can't see me unfortunately but
i am i'm here mr chairman and happy to
respond to anything that you might have
all right i see uh questions on the
screen from the people
at home and i'll start with the
representative heath for a question for
the governor
well thank you mr chair and thank you
governor for taking my question
my question is relative you know me in
education and my love of the university
system
the unique system and and i see that you
have
taken away the endowment fund portion
that goes um to the schools right now
this is one of the most difficult times
for our colleges and universities do you
really think this is a good time to take
that away
uh what have they ever used that
endowment fund for
well right for things like right now um
they've they
you're right they have put it aside and
and they've saved it
for things that they need um but right
now is is one of those times i think
they're all
under extreme duress um and it just
they are very concerned about it yeah so
i understand that
the endowment funds are all limited they
cannot be used for operational costs
they all have those restrictions so
we're providing a lot of capital
for example we put two things
let's go to the university system in
particular they asked for a lot of money
for the state over three bienniums to do
their
bio life sciences building i committed
to that i did it we did this portion
last year we're doing a portion this
year we're not backing out of that
commitment
i've put money in the last time to
double the number of nurses
out of unh which i had to fight to get
back in i know folks wanted to take that
out i fought to get it back in
so we're making those capital
investments for them
the capital in terms of the university
system is is fairly healthy right now
the most important thing is that we're
investing the money into students
we need workers students need to be
living off that and that
that endowment that extra money that
goes into the endowment is more than we
ever anticipated if we weren't meeting
certain commitments with the endowment i
get it but this is money over and above
what was ever projected to go into the
system in the first place and it's
tax-free
so i just think it's an opportunity at
some point it's not about the system it
has to be about the students and the
workforce coming in and so
yeah i know they're under a lot of
pressure to be sure but i think that's
one of the opportunities in bringing the
two systems together at the same time
right allowing the community college and
the entire university system
create those synergies effectively
expanding their
their their physical space their
opportunity for students
all that will come into play in terms of
how the you know where the endowment
goes but i
i'm kind of with you i was always
shocked with the restrictions
that the endowment is self-imposed upon
itself it can't be used
for their everyday costs unfortunately
thank you governor next question comes
from representative
walner
thank you um thank you governor and
thank you
chairman wheeler i i have a couple of
the first one is going to be is sort of
a maybe a
simple question that may be the hardest
question to answer and
that is we're still waiting on house
bill 2. and i'm wondering
uh when we might see that and
it's very hard for the finance committee
to proceed
with their work on the budget until we
have house bill 2 available so i'm just
wondering
what you think that when you think that
might be available sure
matt do you want to answer that
absolutely this is matthew melo
thank you representative for the
question uh hb
2 was delivered to the lba
on the 15th as statutorily required
uh so they are working through the
logistics there
and it's our expectation that you'll see
it relatively soon but at this point
it has been delivered
thank you i mean i think you understand
because
you've put this together so i think you
understand how important hb2
is to the work of the house as we
proceed
um so governor i thought it was i think
it's interesting when you talk about
um the 300 million dollar
cap on the rainy day fund
and i think everyone would agree that um
a goal like that is a is an admirable
goal
but then when i look on page nine of the
executive budget summary which is
basically what i've got to work from
um i see by the end of
2023 we'll be at about
85 million lower than we were
at the end of 2020 and i wonder what
kinds of projections you have around the
rainy day fund
um and where we're going with it sure
um i don't i don't really have any
projections beyond this biennium i think
you know conceptually we've we had to
dig into it a little to make up that
that 50 million dollar hole
we balance the budget here um i think
what we want to look at
is you know how do we grow it in the
future and even if it's 10 million here
and 20 million there and 30 million
there
it's just like putting money away for
your christmas account or whatever or
whatever
it might be so again you know we're able
to kind of stabilize
our losses this i think very well this
time
but you know where we go with that i
think that i'll leave that completely up
to the legislature
but you know my first two budgets we
always had the discussion if we wanted
to increase the rainy day account well
we have a limit well we have a limit
i just don't think we should have a
limit if we have really good economic
times
let's put it in savings doesn't mean you
can spend on infrastructure and capital
projects too of course
but there should always be the ability
to put something in savings without
saying
you know we have a cap so we don't make
any additional projections beyond that i
don't think matt do we i don't think
because i don't think it'd be
appropriate i think we're just trying to
get the economy back on track
you know given all the extra money we
had in the first two budgets after the
first two bienniums that we we went
through here
that's an awesome opportunity and it's
always great to we've i think been very
smart about reinvesting that one-time
money into one-time projects
but partially because you know there was
always a limit on what we could save and
i it's just about creating a flexibility
for the legislature i mean if you don't
want to do it you don't have to do it
but
it just gives like the future
legislatures a lot more flexibility to
save
great thank you i do have one more if i
could if you don't mind i
if you've got an extra minute so my last
question is i i know you've talked a lot
about your um
tax reductions and it's a variety of
different
different reductions but i wonder if you
had
a total value of what those
are worth in this budget how much
total dollars does this represent
a great great question i'm going to look
to matt a little bit i know we discussed
that a couple weeks ago
absolutely and this will be hashed out
more
with ways and means tomorrow morning but
the proposed
changes over the biennium amount to
between 50 and 55 million dollars
there are a number of things in there of
course with the various tax proposals
that are included in this budget
um and we'll be happy to go into detail
with the committee tomorrow morning
as they put together their revenue
estimates based on current law and also
um what hb2 effectively uh will put in
place if it were to become law
great thank you thank you governor
appreciate it thank you mary jane
oh um thank you uh mr chair and thank
you governor for
the presentation and taking questions um
uh representative wallner addressed most
of mine but and again
without house bill 2 it's kind of hard
to wrap
my head around what's occurring but i'm
just interested in
in the anticipated increase in tax
revenues
aligned with the deductions in tax
revenues and just
as an example of course in rooms and
meals we're going to see a spike as
compared
to last year but going back further than
last year
um i really don't see how those two
correlate and is there something in the
house bill 2 that
will help me make sense out of this
because um i agree i'm happy to seek tax
deductions but
um i guess i look at it macro as well as
microly and blooms and meals for example
these
these are comments from local businesses
who have a great concern
about their property taxes which is a
real problem up here
for many of us berlin has a highest rate
in the state um
how can we increase
revenue sharing in rooms and meals um
with this deduction and individually the
comment was simply this
if somebody buys a breakfast for ten
dollars in one of my businesses
that gives them a nickel bag that half a
percent
but in reality it has a big impact on
what's
collected in a hole so how are these
going to match up and how's that going
to happen i don't know if that's a fair
question at this point
but i i'm i'm just really having a hard
time getting my head around these two
um dynamics that are in place sure and
thank you i'm happy to address it
no look i'm the governor everything's a
fair question you give me whatever you
got
um so you're absolutely correct the room
and meals tax is going to be one of the
toughest ones to come back over the long
term
and we're we're i'm still projecting
that that that
overall revenue is still going to be
lower than we've seen in previous years
it's going to take a little while for
that to come back i think we have a
great summer
i'm not saying we're going to
necessarily be breaking rooms and meals
records but where we do
make up for a lot of that on the state
side is the business profits tax the
business enterprise tax
the real estate transfer tax the
cigarette tax
lottery liquor all of these
programs are doing really i mean
record-breaking numbers this year
and so we're not assuming that they're
going exponential by any means but even
if they just go up a couple
percent or so from where we are this
year that creates a lot of the
opportunity that offsets i know a lot of
the concerns that folks have
specifically around room and meal so
i think what we've tried to do is say
look room and meals can affect a lot of
local cities and towns in terms of the
opportunity we give them
you're right reducing the tax a half a
percent
can be somewhat minimal but i get i'll
tell you what it's a heck of a lot
better than going a half percent in the
other direction and over years we always
justified well it's just a quarter
percent here and a half a percent there
and next thing you know we have one of
the highest rooms of meals taxes around
and and we need to be competitive with
other states consumers do look at this
as
someone who used to be in this game of
owning restaurants and hotels i can tell
you
people really do look at these these
opportunities in terms of
um it might only be a nickel off of
a small bill but when you add hotel
rooms and a weekend away and all of that
that stuff it really does add up and so
by
sending this in the right direction and
being able to take advantage of the
strong
business profit business enterprise real
estate tax all these other taxes that
are doing well
that can help offset and create the
opportunity for the cities and towns
remember most of the bet will go into
education right and the rest of it most
of the bpt goes to kind of the general
fund
but so those funds typically don't go
back to cities and towns room and meals
does
so let's create the opportunity there
and get that you know flexibility back
to the cities in town so it's it's an
offset you're absolutely right i don't
think those numbers are going to keep
going up
but they don't have to because they're
offset by the strength of the other
thank you governor representative ober
for a question here in the chamber
is that okay thank you mr chairman
governor thank you for
meeting with us and having your staff
available
you know and i know we dig into this to
find detail
so really what i want to ask is if i
send mr kane
several questions and ask him to send
them over to your budget director will
you
have him dig into them for example one
of the questions i'm interested in
is your new department of energy several
years ago i was part of the group that
wrote the site evaluation
rsa and in hindsight there are these
unintended consequences
i wish we hadn't done and you've now
moved the puc which controls that
into a new agency so i'm kind of curious
in hp2
if you handle some of those things and
i'll give you one example because you
did say
adjudicative commissioners are moved to
an administrative agency
we made a mistake and had the site
evaluation committee
actually do some of the follow-up and
it's in the state law unfortunately
that probably should have gone to des on
the permitting and
some of the certifications every now and
then we talk about trying to do
something well you're doing something
so i'd like to work with matt and see if
we got rid of some of those niggles and
would you mind if we
send in some written questions to your
staff
i would i would love it again look you
folks have been on the front lines of
this especially you lynn and some others
a lot longer than we have and and that's
a hugely valuable
understanding because you've heard the
direct testimony you understand the
pushes and pulls and what maybe has been
tried and what hasn't so
no your questions would be i i'm begging
you for the questions because that helps
us understand
you know where conceptually maybe we
haven't haven't planned it all the way
out but there's no doubt that we can
make it a better system and so yeah send
over whatever you want and we'll we'll
happy to work with you that'd be fun
thank you very much representative lynn
for a question in the chamber
thank you uh thank you uh governor um i
i have to say just some follow-up to
representative ober's question i i think
the idea
of the department of energy makes
tremendous sense
to separate the sort of adjudicatory
uh functions from uh from the management
administration of the uh of the
department i
i'm wondering along the same lines when
you talked about the
the parole the changes you've proposed
for the parole board
my understanding is that and i think
it's i think it
it makes a lot of sense i saw that
you're proposing to make the chair of
the parole board a full-time position
which i think
makes makes a lot of sense i'm i'm
wondering though
if my understanding is that the parole
board
right now also has some
administrative kind of kinds of
responsibilities
um probably probably nowhere near as
great as the as the public utilities
commission does
but still has some and i'm wondering if
it would make sense
to make a similar kind of change with
the parole board that is to let them
have
let them have their adjudicative
responsibility as the parole board
but perhaps put them you know more fully
under the department of corrections
administratively or maybe under the
department of safety but
in other words have somebody else do the
sort of administrative
stuff that the parole board
does now i think that sounds like a
great idea
yeah i don't think we really thought of
it that way but that would make a lot of
sense so
definitely something we should look into
matt what do you think i mean is that
possible
absolutely happy to work with your
representative on what some of those
details might look like
terrific thank you sounds like that's
why we have hp2
any other questions i don't see any
hands on the screen
everybody all set work together on this
and i know it'll come out right
it always does well thank you guys i
appreciate the time and again any
questions you have just
you know send them right along um you
know we've we've the good news is
i've actually done this a couple times
now i'm getting much better at it
i i really do believe it's one of the
best budgets we've ever put forth given
tough economic times but huge
opportunity going forward
and we just got a great team here so
we'll work with you on any issue you
want and i just appreciate the time to
to present it and
and i know whatever whatever turns out
it's going to be a great budget in the
end
thank you governor thank you
we'll see you all right is matt going to
follow you i guess not
all right i am here all right
mattis here all right
any further questions at this time for
mata shall we get to him with the
details later as we go through the
budget
and he hands up on the committee that's
remote
any uh questions in the chamber
all right we'll get to work on this
right away thank you all very much for
coming and thank the lba
for setting this up and we'll see you
all
thank you chairman
you